[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMIR HUSAIN: So the book is
called "The Sentient Machine,"
and it really is a varied book.
It starts off with some
philosophical ponderings
on what the advent of
AI really means for us.
There are, as you know,
some existential concerns
regarding the advent of
more and more powerful AI,
AGI, and then ASI.
And lots of very
worthy scholars have
written volumes about these.
For example, Nick Bostrom,
"Superintelligence,"
which I'm sure many of you
have heard of, if not read.
And then beyond
that there's also
discussion around essentially
these two fears that keep
sort of rearing their
head in different ways.
But one, that AI will
take away all our jobs
and it might render
us useless when
it gets to a certain level
of complexity and capability.
And the other is that
it might kill us.
And, of course, that has
many different aspects
and situations under which
that fear manifests itself.
But, in a nutshell, those
are two real conversations
that are happening these days.
And for this audience
I'll also tell you
that these are not just
hypothetical or philosophical
quandaries and
questions anymore.
They are now being
played out at the highest
levels of government.
So SparkCognition works
in three principal areas,
national security, industry,
and energy, and finance.
And I won't talk much
about our own work.
This is a talk about the book.
This is not to talk about
SparkCognition or my work,
per se.
But because of that background
I end up meeting with and having
some pretty
interesting discussions
with the senior-most
military leadership not just
in this country, but also,
for example, in allied states
in Europe.
About two weeks ago I
addressed the NATO council
on their adaptation report that
was about to come out and how,
believe it or not, AI
will play a great role
in the new adaptation
report that was just
released based on the writings
that General John Allen-- who
is my collaborator and also
on the SparkCognition board--
and I published
earlier this year.
So that's just
one example to say
that artificial
intelligence is becoming
real in many, many ways.
And perhaps in narrow
domains initially,
but the capabilities
are widening.
And for some of these
existential concerns
that people have expressed,
for example that it'll
take our jobs away, realize that
we don't need commander data.
You know, AGI-level
capability, for those sorts
of things to be threats.
ANI capability implemented in
many different areas can lead
to 30%, 40%,
god-knows-what-percent
unemployment.
That remains to be seen.
And that's for
developed countries.
On the other hand, for
undeveloped countries
or developing
countries, they have
invested a lot in
their burgeoning
what they call their
"demographic dividend,"
people that have been brought
out from conditions of sort
of under-privilege, and
are now being educated
and are being made
available to do
complex tasks in the economy.
Well, some of
those complex tasks
might be subsumed before those
generations get an opportunity
to really make a mark.
So there's that emerging
sense of the fallacy
of the burgeoning middle
class in developing countries,
and whether they'll be able
to play the role that we once
thought they would
be able to play.
We don't know.
We'll see at what rate
these technologies progress.
But my point here
is that already we
are at a point
where the discussion
around artificial intelligence
is partly technology,
but it's also partly policy.
And in my own case I've tried
to bring these things together,
and in the book you see the
science, the philosophy,
as well as elements of policy
because ultimately we have
to do something about this.
And I'll tell you later
on as we get into this,
for example, some
of the discussions
around bans and
autonomous weapons.
I've been quite deeply involved
in all of those debates
and have met with a lot
of folks that really
do matter in that debate.
So we'll go through that.
The way I'll
structure the talk is
I'll start off with
a very brief reading.
And, you know, the beginning
of all of these sessions
ends up being
different just based
on what chapter you choose.
So here we were talking
about autonomous weapons.
Maybe I'll start with the
beginning of a chapter called
"Warfare and AI," and then we'll
talk about more broadly some
of the content in the book.
But I've also structured
a presentation
that takes us a little
bit beyond the book.
There are some
concepts here which,
for accomplished
computer scientists that
are in the audience, might
seem to be very basic,
and you may be
familiar with them.
And I'll go over those
quickly if they become boring.
But then we can get into
some of the other issues
and some of the problems that
I think we still need to solve.
So that's how I'll
go, and of course I'm
open to questions at
any time and comments.
I would welcome that.
OK.
So for those of you who do
have the book, on page 87
I'll start with a very brief
reading of this chapter that
is titled "Warfare and AI."
"Join me for a thought
experiment originally published
in the US Naval Institute's
proceedings journal
and conceived of by my friend
and collaborator General John
Allen of the United
States Marine
Corps, a four-star general,
and past deputy commander of US
Central Command.
It is January 2,
2018, and a captain
is contemplating damage to his
ship after a surprise attack.
This, however, was
no ordinary attack.
He is about to
discover that this
was a massive, widespread,
strategic surprise.
Our captain and his crew had not
anticipated the incoming swarm
because neither he nor his ship
recognized that their systems
were under cyber attack.
The undetected cyber
activity not only
compromised the sensors but
locked out defensive systems,
leaving the ship almost
entirely helpless.
The kinetic strikes
came in waves
as a complex swarm of
drones tore into the ship.
It was attacked by a cloud
of autonomous systems
moving together with purpose,
yet also dynamically reacting
to one another and to the ship.
More than anything,
the speed of the attack
stunned and overwhelmed
the sailors.
Though the IT specialists
on board the ship
were able to release
some defensive systems
from the clutches of the cyber
intrusion, the rest of the crew
simply did not have enough
decision-making time to react.
Mere seconds.
And in these few seconds
some of the sailors
ascertained with their
limited situational awareness
that the enemy's autonomous
cyber and kinetic systems
were collaborating.
But in a matter of minutes
the entire attack was over.
The captain survived and
courageously remained
on the bridge, but
he was badly wounded
as was much of his crew.
Fires were burning
out of control
and the ship was already
listing badly from flooding.
Because of the
damage the captain
was unable to communicate
with the damage control
assistant who was,
herself, badly wounded.
It appeared that some of
the autonomous platforms
knew exactly where
to strike the ship
both to maximize the
damage and reduce
the chances of survivability.
The captain's ability
to command his ship
was now badly compromised,
and the flooding
was out of control.
After surveying the
entire situation
he realizes he must make a call
that no American skipper has
made for generations.
He issues the order
to abandon ship."
OK.
So going through this you might
wonder if this is fiction.
It is.
You might wonder if this is
entirely imagined fiction
with no grounding in truth.
It is not.
It was very interesting--
this past year
I had the opportunity to
travel through the Middle East.
And, as you know, there are
many numerous active conflicts
going on in the Middle East.
And many of them
are conflicts that
are taking an
asymmetric sort of tilt
where you've got somebody like
the Houthis, as an example,
in Yemen, or you've got ISIS
terror organizations in Syria
and some parts of Iraq.
And you've got then
on the other side,
for the most part,
well-armed military forces
with sophisticated radars
and patriot missiles
and so on and so forth.
And let me just tell you
that I know for a fact
that much of what is
described here-- maybe not
with this level of
nation-state sophistication.
You know, because
here what we describe
is a swarm of
improvised UCAVs coming
in with pretty sophisticated
vision and other recognition
capabilities going for
a well-protected asset.
But similar scenarios
have actually
played out in the current
conflict in the Middle East.
The DIY AI improvised
flying IED is already here.
Two weeks ago the Convention
for Conventional Weapons--
which is a little
awkwardly-named, but--
CCW at the UN got
together, I think
for the third or fourth time
over three or four years.
And there are 107 member states
of this organization in the UN.
And every year they've
gotten together
and expressed their dire concern
over the potential spread
of autonomous weapons,
and what they must do.
And, of course, you
may remember the famous
what's called the "Elon Musk
letter," which was really not
Elon Musk's letter.
The most recent one was
written by Professor Toby
Walsh from the University of
New South Wales in Australia.
He's an AI professor there.
And of course Elon
Musk was a signatory.
And then the letter
was presented
as a desire or a request
for a ban, which it was not.
It was a request
for a discussion.
And at the end of this
most recent session
107 countries couldn't
even get together
after four years
of debate and agree
on what the definition of
an autonomous weapon is.
In the meanwhile the
Kalishnikov Bureau--
which many of you may have heard
of, which is a Russian weapons
manufacturer--
announced that they were testing
a UGV, an unmanned ground
vehicle, which in field
tests had already shown
better-than-human performance.
Now, you may doubt these claims.
You may think
these are oversold,
but wait a year or two.
Similarly, China
announced that they
were Fielding a AI-powered
cruise missiles,
and the MIG Bureau announced
that their new next-gen MIG
aircraft would have AI
auto-pilot operating
to control the flight
envelope at hypersonic speeds.
So this is just one vignette.
This is just one
side of AI which
is, it is a technology
that brings a distributed
autonomy at large-scale
to the field of battle.
It is a strategic
level up, if you will,
in terms of capability.
And no significant player,
no significant military
is going to ignore this.
And just to give you further
evidence of this, of the 107
countries that were at
this CCW session there
were only 22 that came out and
said, we are in favor of a ban.
Of all the nuclear
states there was only one
which supported the ban.
And of all significant
militaries in the world,
all states with significant
militaries in the world, only
two supported the ban.
The largest militaries,
the countries
with the largest number
of nuclear weapons
all argued for
further discussion.
Let's push this
off to next year.
So that's where we are.
That's just one vignette.
But with that, let me
start talking about some
of the things that
we cover in the book.
So what's quite
clear to me now is
that we've made enough
progress in several areas
where a new form of
intelligence really is coming.
I mean, it's no longer
sort of "The Wizard of Oz,"
a man hiding behind a curtain.
It's no longer just large
numbers of "if, then, else"
statements.
And while we keep uncovering
every now and then company X
and company Y outsourcing
some activity that they call
intelligent but
really it's going out
to the
Amazon-Mechanical-Turk-type
situation, really aside
from all of those things,
an increasing level of
intelligence is being built.
And with deep
learning in particular
we've had great impact
on perception tasks.
You know, where we
want to, for example,
classify-- we want to
perceive something and extract
complex patterns,
and even patterns
across temporal boundaries.
We've been able to do that
very well with deep learning.
And now we're sort of running
forward with reinforcement
learning, with lots
of new innovations.
And the key thing
to take away there
is, we're moving from
the domain of perception
to the domain of action.
And even within
reinforcement learning now
we have the ability
to train systems up,
maybe in simulated
environments and with some
of the breakthroughs that
are taking place in transfer
learning, we take the learning
that's done in a simulator
and translate that
to the real world.
So this is not a talk
about the current state
of the art in all
three of these areas,
but just a couple of minutes
to say that this is becoming
quite real and, indeed, a
new form of intelligence
if not sentience is coming.
Sentience, I think, is far away.
So with this, just
a quick background.
One of the things that I think
I do differently in the book
is simply a consequence
of my own background.
So I'm a serial entrepreneur.
I've been based in Austin.
I went to school at UT
Austin, computer science,
and have done a number of
software companies since then.
And SparkCognition was a company
I founded back in mid-2013.
The company focuses,
as I mentioned,
on national security,
finance, and industry.
In fact, we're a Google
partner on a number
of different things.
And the company has grown
really, really fast.
In fact, it's the fastest
growing company in Austin.
Now, with that
being said, that's
the business side of things.
Right?
How you actually
take this technology
and make it work and
make it solve problems
for the largest
companies in the world.
But the other side
of this is that I
come to this not just purely
from a business background.
I am a computer
scientist by training.
I love computer science.
I live computer science.
And I serve on the
board of advisors
of UTCS, which is one
of the great, really,
pleasures when I'm able
to spend much time there.
So it brings sort of
the business aspect,
the practicality of making these
things work with the science
and attempting to
advance the science.
And then finally the center
of a new American security
is one of the premier
think tanks in DC.
And I serve on
their advisory board
for artificial intelligence.
In fact, about two or three
weeks ago I was in DC.
We had a CNAS conference
on AI and what this would
mean for autonomous weapons.
And there were lots of
generals serving and otherwise,
and many policymakers
in the audience.
But we also had
Eric Schmidt there.
And I had an interesting
discussion with Eric.
And one of the
topics that came up
was, well, how long,
given that China just
announced their 2030 AI
plan, which many of you
may have seen--
it's an investment
of $150 billion
of government spending
over the next five years.
In 2015 the US government
spent $1.1 billion on AI,
and in 2016 we spent a
whopping $1.2 billion on AI.
Again, the Chinese
government has
committed-- just governmental
spending-- $150 billion
over five years.
And if you read the 2030
AI report it says by 2030
we will be the
dominant AI player.
In addition to that, they also
talk about all the applications
of AI, and a big chunk of
that is military applications.
So here we were in DC at this
conference, and I asked Eric--
I said, Eric, you know, I have
a view, but what's your view?
How soon do you think China
will be able to overtake
the US in core AI capability?
And it's on video, and
then there will not
be a lot of articles
written about it,
but he said five years.
I don't disagree with him.
It sounds very aggressive, but
the rate at which progress is
being made, the rate at which--
just if you look at Face++
and the rate at which they are
improving their
vision algorithms.
And a few years ago I
remember people used to cite,
well, you know, AI
papers in China-- sure,
they're publishing
a lot of AI papers,
but they're not as good as us.
Well, now that's really
not the case anymore.
And it sort of reminds
me of the whole reaction
that we've had to many
other countries that
have been catching up.
Oh, they probably
just copied it.
It's kind of like a fake.
You know, sort of kind of there
but it isn't the same thing.
And then suddenly,
very quickly you
realize that folks
are catching up.
And where we are in our
current situation as a country
is that we're doing
things like preventing
the spouses of h1-b
immigrants from working,
which means that fewer smart
people will be able to come in.
We're trying to ban entry
from a number of countries
and limiting the
number of smart people
that we'll be able
to bring into the US.
So while you have a near-peer
competitor putting $150 billion
to your 1.2 billion,
you're also then strangling
some of the core
elements of innovation
that have historically
been so useful for you.
That, I think, is bad timing.
So moving on to another element.
In a lot of these talks people
ask just the simple question
of, well, what does it mean
for a machine to think?
This is obviously a
very complex question,
and there's many,
many different ways
in which a machine can think.
And we tend to describe
things in the context
of a neural network where
you take a neural network,
you give it a lot
of data, and then
you can ask it a question
about what you've trained it on
and it'll either classify
or, in a regression sense,
give you some sort of an answer.
But I figured that from
a visual perspective
there's many ways
machines can think.
And AI isn't just
machine learning,
there's many other things
in AI as well, for example
search-based optimization.
So here one way that you can
think in a problem domain
is, let's just take the
simplest example of tic-tac-toe.
Given just a couple of
rules you can pre-generate
all the possible outcomes.
And then what is perceived
by the human player
to be a smart move is simply
a goal-seeking behavior
where I know what
a win looks like,
and I've generated
the tree or the graph,
and I'm trying to
traverse the graph
to find the most efficient path
to what I know to be a win.
And that's one way
in which you can
make machines appear to think.
But we also know that not every
problem has such a small state
space.
So there are problems--
I mean, even games-- take
another game, like Pac-Man,
where--
where is Ms. Pac-Man
quite at this moment,
and how many of the golden
nuggets have been consumed,
and what's the direction
of each one of the foes,
and did you eat
the berry or not?
I mean, there's a
lot of variability
in that state space.
So that's the kind of thing
that you wouldn't want
to just encode in this way.
So there now we try to do things
like reinforcement learning,
where we just start off
and start playing the game,
and you end up and
you die pretty quick,
but maybe you made 50 points.
And what you are
trying to remember
is what sequence of tasks
got you to those 50 points.
The first ones that you took
are pretty much worth the 50
points, because they lead to
you getting the 50 points.
But as you move further
along in that stack of moves,
you realize that the closer
you get to 50 the less
valuable each one of those
more recent moves were because,
goddammit, the last
one got you killed.
So that can be very valuable.
And so you can have this
sense of, well, let me--
and, again, there's many, many
different approaches to this--
but you can have an
element of randomness to
where, let me try and
get the maximum reward
but when the level of reward
goes below a certain threshold
I'm going to try
different things.
And maybe I find something
that's more interesting.
So this is sort of like
a self-pruned search.
In reinforcement learning,
in just layman's terms,
it's sort of like a
self-pruned search
where you start
off with something,
and you don't abandon that but
you just look for improvements
where you can find them.
And we've seen great
progress with this.
Now, another thing
that I will point out
is that even in
this idea where you
are generating entire
states-- by the way, stuff
that's not fashionable
people stop thinking about.
But there's a lot
of problems that
can be smartly-pruned to
where these sorts of solutions
are still pretty good solutions.
I mean, you don't hear
A-Star Search much now,
but if you apply data
properly to A-Star Search
and you come up with
clever heuristics on how
to prune what gets generated
and what gets searched,
there's a lot of problems that
you can solve pretty cleverly
with A-Star Search.
But anyway, in this
particular case
where you see the full
tree, one thing to note
is that generating
these states sometimes
can be incredibly simple.
And that's one concept
that I'll build on here.
So here what you had to know
to generate this whole tree
is that for every progression
you can only change or add
one symbol at a time.
Right?
So if you've got
naughts and crosses
either you can add one
naught or one cross.
You can't add two
naughts in one go.
You need to know what
the winning state is.
And that's sort of--
we all know a diagonal
or a line or a horizontal bar.
And then with every step here,
as you step through the tree,
in every layer you are
alternating symbols.
So first you get a naught,
then you get a cross,
then you get a
naught, and so on.
That's all.
That's all that you need to know
in order to generate something
like this.
And so is that sort of
this mind-altering fact
in the context of
noughts and crosses?
Not really.
But it does get to say that
very, very simple things, when
iterated upon, when
dealt with recursion,
can create tremendous
complexity.
That can be useful.
So a seed of
specification can create
something that is very, very
large, very, very useful,
and sometimes a
little unexpected.
These are concepts that, at
least in two different places--
and we talk about
the Game of Life
briefly in "The Sentient
Machine," but what I cover
is just the basic introduction.
Stephen Wolfram, who's
the creator of Mathematica
and somebody that I've
followed for many years, a very
interesting thinker--
in his book "A New
Kind of Science"
he spends almost
200 pages just going
over different forms, different
variations of the Game of Life.
And these, again, if you--
how many of you are familiar
with the Game of Life?
All of you.
OK.
Almost.
And so, again, these are really,
really very simple rules.
And what Wolfram
shows is that you
can have these incredible
levels of complex non-repeating
patterns that come from
very, very basic rules.
Another sort of more in lines of
sort of continuous mathematics
is this notion of fractals.
And there's two things
that I want to quickly say.
So one-- since you are
familiar with the Game of Life,
I'm sure you've seen
simulations like this.
But to me every time I see
stuff like this I'm amazed.
You know, there's
these creatures
with, like, distinct behavior
that evolve every time.
And some of them find
stability and others oscillate
between two states.
And then you have some movement.
You have this artifact called a
glider that just sort of walks
across, diagonally usually.
You have these blobs
that can combine,
and then what comes out of
that is at least not visually
immediately predictive.
And these can be very
complex sort of behaviors.
And looking at that does
seem to be like there's
something going on here.
And of course we
know what's going
on here is just very
simple, three simple rules.
But the manifest
complexity is far more
than those three simple rules--
an initial reading of those
three simple rules would imply.
The same is the case really
when you start thinking
about fractals, because--
I mean, this one is
the Mandelbrot fractal,
and Benoit Mandelbrot
came up with an expression
which is, yea-long.
I mean, that's it.
Right?
That's the amount
of math that's being
generated into this structure.
And the reason why we're
going into this is that--
I mean, again, for
those of you who've
read "Ender's Game," the
book, not the movie--
you'll realize or
recognize or remember
that there is one
comment in there that
was made where Ender was
at this training facility
and he was given access
to a large computer.
And somebody pulls him away
and says, what are you doing?
And he says, I'm traveling
through the fractal,
and now the fractal is larger
than the known universe.
So when I read
that as a teenager
it sort of stuck in my head.
I don't think that when the
book was written that computers
had actually generated a fractal
that was larger than the known
universe, but now there
are many examples of this.
So to think that this much
math, this much specification,
this much code can
generate something
with un-ending complexity that
is unpredictable, actually,
and unique at so many
different levels,
to me is pretty amazing.
And the two ingredients
of that, of course,
are the specification and the
iteration and the recursion.
And that gets me to one of the
points that I make in the book
also about the universe being
computable in a different way.
So you've heard
Elon Musk recently
talk about how the universe
might be a simulator.
I actually came across
that concept in my youth.
A gentleman by the
name of Ed Fredkin
had written extensively on this.
And then when I
started digging deeper
I realized that Konrad
Zuse, even back in the '40s,
had talked about these concepts.
And Ed Fredkin-- you
know, this article--
my father gave it to me--
it was published in a magazine.
It was called, "Is the
Universe a Computer?"
And the idea there was not so
much Elon Musk's idea, which
is that we're all living
inside a simulation, which
is one type of
simulator inquiry,
but the other idea
was, is the universe
fundamentally computable?
Like everything we see, is it
a consequence of computation?
Many years later my sister
became a string theorist,
and I tried to get at least
a workable understanding
of string theory in my many
conversations with her.
And one day she sort of
lost her patience with me
and said, listen, all of what
we write in words in English,
it's just to sort of point you
roughly in the right direction.
If you want to understand any
of what we are really saying
you have to work
through the math.
None of this really
translates in language.
And the one thing, of
course, from string theory--
which is very interesting-- is
the rediscovery, potentially,
of what the Greeks
called the "atom."
You know, a-tom, "that
which cannot be cut."
They were in search of
that final particle that
was truly indivisible.
And perhaps with
the Planck length,
it's not so much the
particle but it's the fact
that we know how small
a particle can be.
We have-- if the
universe is Minecraft,
we know the smallest size
of the pixel, of the block,
within which there can be
nothing else other than just
one symbol contained.
And what is that symbol?
That symbol can be a
configuration of a string.
So in that sense I
started thinking, well,
if that's the case
then you essentially
can model the universe as a data
structure that has these fixed
size cells that are
Planck-length size cells which
have a number of
these symbols in them.
And in that sense it's
computable, right?
So, who knows?
Lots of different
people are thinking
about this in different ways.
Max Tegmark has his book, and
he talks about some of this.
Of course Ed Fredkin and
Konrad Zuse, like I said,
have been thinking about
this for many decades.
And Stephen Wolfram
has his take on it.
But there's something here.
There's something
here about the fact
that computational constructs
on very, very small recipes
can create this sort of
useful emergent complexity.
And now, as we
know, computers can
create computational realities.
I can today basically
build my own world.
I start the book
off by saying that I
got into computers
because at the age of four
I ran into a Commodore 64.
I saw hangman playing
on the screen,
and it blew my mind
because I had never
seen a TV screen play out
what I wanted it to play out.
And yet there was a keyboard
which I could touch,
and suddenly everything
was fungible.
This notion of programmability
for a four-year-old mind
was completely mind-blowing.
And from there it went to,
well, what can I not create?
And now, of course, we
know we can pretty much
create what we want.
And even the physical
dimensions of all of this
are not gated in
any way by reality.
These are some just fundamental
things from computer science
that we ought to realize,
that the basic constructs
of computer science--
the magnificational constructs,
the iteration, the recursion
and so on and so forth, applied
to very basic specifications--
can yield a lot.
And then if you start
thinking about the mind
of a machine, which any
such thinking is partial
because we don't know.
There's a lot to be done.
There's a lot of
questions to be answered.
But think about things just in
terms of differences with us.
Well, one thing we
know pretty well
is that our brain fits into
a relatively small cranium
and consumes about 20 watts.
It's very, very efficient.
It has a very large
number of neurons.
number of connections.
But for all of its efficiency
and size, et cetera,
it's not really
substantially going
to consume more than 20
watts in its present form.
While we don't have a computer
that's as efficient as a brain
yet, we do know that our
computers can consume
much more than 20 watts.
They don't have to sit inside
a physical cranium that's
the size of ours.
Perfect recall, which is that--
and this is
interesting because we
tend to sort of
live in the moment,
we get what we need
from that experience,
and we tend to forget.
And in many ways
this is good for us.
It's good for us actually
because it avoids overload.
And this is common with
another thing that we do,
which is very
aggressive pruning.
So we tend to go down
certain solutions
and we tend to discard things
that sound ridiculous to us.
So the reason why that move
that Lisa Dole and others found
so magical, even
all the commentators
that were great
practitioners of Go,
was because it just
was one of those things
that they were
willing to discard.
Nobody has done this before.
I've never done this before.
In this situation why the hell
would you ever do this before?
It becomes sort of common sense.
It becomes the kind of thing
that is system-one thinking.
You know, if you
go back to Kahneman
and his theory about how we
think, thinking fast and slow,
and we start pruning things.
But a machine intelligence
can actually be in a place,
can take everything in, can
learn what it can at that time,
but the original experience
is entirely preserved.
So if its ability to
extract more knowledge
from that experience
improves over time,
the original data and full
fidelity is still available.
In fact my colleague,
Professor Bruce Porter,
who is the chairman of the UT
computer science department,
is working on a long
running project that
does something
like this, which is
that he's developing machine--
so, natural language
understanding software.
And he's been working in
that area for 35-plus years.
And his approach is that
what I can't understand
with my current
algorithms in the corpus
will get tagged
in a special way.
And every iteration
of the algorithm
will go back and look at what
the previous iteration was not
able to understand.
So this sort of
constant learning
with the availability of the
fully-preserved information,
that's not how we usually
think about things.
We filter out a lot of stuff.
And then, of course,
there's other things,
like being disembodied.
I mean, there's no need to
protect a physical body at all.
There's no need to comply
with a size limitation.
And, of course, we know
about the faster processing.
So the question here is,
if human beings had evolved
with an eye also on
the back of our head,
would we be
fundamentally different?
Probably.
I mean, a lot of the
amygdala-driven response
that we have now in
situations of fear
where we are aware that there
could be something pretty
close behind us
that could get us
and therefore we have to keep
at a high state of readiness--
well, maybe we would be
less neurotic with an eye
at the back of our head.
Who knows?
So these are all
the kinds of things
that, of course, in
machine intelligence
we get to experiment with.
One other element--
very practical element--
of what's happening
right now is--
so we're talking
about AI of the future
and the mind of a
machine and so on,
but what's happening right now?
You know and in the
valley everybody knows,
Marc Andreessen said a
while ago that software
is eating the world.
And that's sort of
a euphemistic thing,
but for me it's a very
real, physical thing.
So this is a traditional
combustion engine,
and you've got an electric
motor on to the right-hand side.
And you've got valves and spark
plugs and EFIs and carburetors,
and you've got a
block, and you've
got all sorts of
things going on here.
And each one of them
has a specific function.
Each one of these
mechanical elements
performs a specific function.
And then you've got
an electric motor
where most of the capability
of the mechanical elements
has been transformed
into software.
The EFI, for example--
how you gate energy,
is now all software.
So the reduced number
of physical components
in that picture
on the right is--
when you subtract that from
the picture on the left,
that is the amount of physical
stuff that software just ate.
And there are similar
pictures like this
across a whole host of areas.
We work very
closely with Boeing.
I can tell you that
the future of aviation,
even though it's not
going to be very imminent,
but Boeing's
invested in a company
that's doing electrical engines
for proper commuter aircraft.
You know, not the
size of a 777 yet,
but multi-seat commuter
aircraft, short-haul electric.
That changes a lot of things.
If you look at what companies
like Velopter and EHANG are
doing-- the Chinese
company, EHANG--
with autonomous drones.
The city of-- actually,
the country of UAE
appointed an AI
minister recently,
and they've expressed their
desire to build the world's
first autonomous
flying taxi service.
And they, in fact, even signed a
contract with a Chinese company
and they're now looking to
move that to somebody else.
But they are committed
to doing that.
So these things, even in the
narrow context, are happening.
And they're certainly
coming to bear.
Last point here I'll
make, and then we we'll
kind of stop for questions.
Important thing is not so much
whether AI will do everything.
The important thing, I
think, is what all can ANI
do in a given period of time?
And if you look at
the right there,
that's a study that
was done recently,
a poll with many AI experts.
And you may agree or
disagree with some of those,
and some of them may be
optimistic and some of them
may be pessimistic.
But, for example, the
ability to assemble any
Lego in the next 10 years or so.
Now we know that when
you can assemble any Lego
you're not just assembling Lego.
It's a fairly general-purpose
capability that you have.
Manufacturing robots have
been increasing in huge ways.
If you look at warehouse
management just five years ago
and what we have now in
terms of warehouse management
capability, it's tremendous.
And nobody's going to want to
discuss the poetry of Robert
Frost or Rumi with a
warehouse management robot,
but it is going to
have an impact on jobs.
And so part of what my
push really has been,
particularly on the policy
side, has been, look,
we hear all the
platitudes that people
say "the machines are coming,
the machines are coming,"
but really it's like
any other revolution.
It's like any other
technological area
of progress--
era of progress, rather--
where there'll be new jobs.
And all these people
that are displaced here
will find things to go do there.
And I think that's
just complete hogwash.
I think that's nonsense.
I think the two things
that we've done--
one, we've replicated
human muscle
with the steam engine, which
basically we got ourselves
out of every job
that requires muscle.
And now by replicating not
the entire mind, but even
parts of the mind, slivers of
the mind that are good enough
to perform a function,
we are at a point
where we can automate
much of what we
do in many, many professions.
And that's all we are.
We are muscle and mind.
I mean, that's what it is.
So there's no third thing
to go and replicate.
And with this, the impact may
not be us in barcaloungers a-la
"Wall-E," but it might
be 30%, 40% unemployment.
And who needs to start
thinking about this?
The people that need to
start thinking about this
are the people
who make policies.
And there are some countries
where, for example, they've
gone and they've started
experimenting with things
like a minimum wage, essentially
minimum guaranteed income.
There are countries like
France which are progressively
reducing the number
of work hours
so that automation
can pick up the slack
and people can get time back.
I don't know.
Bill Gates has proposed
a tax on robots.
I am not proposing a specific
solution, but what I am saying
is that the level at which
this discussion is happening
with the inevitability of
the impact right ahead of us,
I think that level
of discussion is
insignificant and insufficient.
And I started this talk talking
about autonomous weapons
and sharing with you
the rate at which
the CCW UN is making
progress on even defining
what an autonomous weapon
is while at the same time
autonomous weapons
are being deployed.
And here again we might find
ourselves in a situation
where more and more automation
will make it into factories,
into retail spaces.
We're working on an engagement
with a large company in Dubai
to do concierge intelligence
based on natural language
processing in retail stores.
It's going to start
off being interesting
and sort of like how do you
get people in, into the shop,
and you attract them with
something that's new and shiny.
But it'll get pretty
good pretty quickly.
So that's kind of where we are.
And my hope is that
we can, with all
of the work that we're doing
and all the conversations we're
having in Brussels
and DC and elsewhere,
is to get the leaders
of our nation,
and frankly the leaders of the
Western world, to take notice
and to truly focus themselves
in developing policies that
can sustain this AI powered
world of the future.
So with that, I'll stop and
see if there are any questions.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
My question was mostly
about, you know, the ending,
the last thing you talked about.
Right?
I often hear about the need
for more discussion, policy
changes.
But it really alarms
me, because when
you see the kind
of discourse that
our elected
representatives often
have about even, like, really
basic technological issues
you realize they have no idea
what they're talking about.
Right?
And it really
worries me when they
might be having
discussions about things
like this which are potentially
very complex and nuanced.
Is there a solution to this?
Like, you mentioned even
that, you know, they're
having discussions
about defining things
that are already happening.
Right?
Like, what can we do about this?
AMIR HUSAIN: That's a
very difficult question.
I think one thing that we
should do is to not give up.
So what I'm personally
doing is that I
try, to the best of my
ability, to insert myself
into every forum where I
can impact policymakers,
where we can go and
share this story
and explain to them the quantum
of impact that is coming.
Two weeks ago I was speaking
at the Texas CEO Summit,
which is an economic summit.
So they talk about how
the state's growing
and what the future
of work will be.
But you have leaders--
state leadership, economic
leaders and so on present
there.
And I thought that what I
said may have been surprising,
but it was well received.
People were willing to listen.
I've briefed pretty much
everyone at the Pentagon.
And I told you I met
with Eric Schmidt.
That was also in connection
with a CNAS event.
So that's the one
thing I know how to do,
which is to be out there and
keep repeating the message over
and over.
And then, as a consequence of
doing that, you find allies.
You find kindred spirits.
You find in an exchange--
I didn't know how Eric was
going to answer that question,
but he happened to
answer that question
in a way that supported
the basic thrust of what
we were talking about.
And that became
25 media articles.
You know, General
Allen and I recently
wrote in "Foreign Policy."
That got reprinted in the
National newspaper of the UAE.
It showed up in Canada.
It showed up everywhere.
So again, we can't force change
physically, but what we can do
is influence huge numbers
of minds, and in doing
that we can find allies.
You know, this is a mind shift.
So I don't expect
people that have
no grounding and no interest
in this area to suddenly see
the light, but I
do hope that we'll
be able to find around them
influencers and shapers that
can at least carry the
day and move them forward
in the direction that
the country, the world
needs them to move in.
It's not an easy process and
it's not a direct answer,
but that's the best
I know how to do.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AMIR HUSAIN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
The title of the book and the
talk is "The Sentient Machine,"
and we haven't talked much
about sentience right here.
AMIR HUSAIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But that is a goal
of many of the teams working
towards this, self-aware
machines with morality
and ethics of their own, real
viewpoints and perspectives.
Now, that might be five
years away, 40 years away,
but it would be a good idea
to have some kind of idea
of how to deal with that when it
gets here before it gets here.
So in the circles
that you talk in,
is there any
discussion about ways
to manage, regulate, and
interact with AI other
than as property?
AMIR HUSAIN: That's
a very good question.
And by the way, I
completely concur
with your original observation
that the title of the book
is "The Sentient
Machine"-- in this talk
we didn't really get into
what is sentience and so on.
The book does cover that.
My view of it.
And just to give you a very
quick sort of response to that,
in my view intelligence-- and a
lot of people agree with this,
but not all--
intelligence is about
goal-directed behavior.
And the larger your goals,
usually, the more intelligent
we assess that entity to be.
And to me sentience is a
combination of intelligence
and self-awareness.
So what I talk about
in the book is sort of,
"I think, therefore I am."
That school of thought, of the
principle proof even to myself
that I exist is that I can
externalize myself and then
observe myself thinking, and
then say, aha, I must be.
And then from there we go on.
But that being said,
your question really
is whether, in these practical
domains, whether there's
a realization that--
so the thrust of
your question really
is managing sentience
or not creating
sentience in these machines
so there is nothing to manage.
AUDIENCE: No.
So the government manages
and interacts with people,
but the government
does not manage us
as though we are property.
AMIR HUSAIN: Right.
AUDIENCE: All of the
talks that I've heard
are about managing
AI as property.
Are there any alternative talks
going on that you've observed?
AMIR HUSAIN: Yes.
I mean, I am part of that
alternative talk myself.
What I say in this book is
that even if you go back
to our religious traditions--
not to take them literally--
but if you go back
to our religious
traditions, what
made Adam great was the fact
that he could take action
on his own.
And up until the
creation of Adam,
in our Abrahamic
system of religions,
the angels, et cetera, could do
just what they were told to do.
And the fact that Adam
could do what he wanted to
was what made him great.
If we now are after millennia
and millennia of evolution
poised at the juncture where we
can be the kind of creator that
can create something that
has its own will, to whatever
limited degree--
because we haven't figured out
how much free will we have--
but to whatever
limited degree, I
don't think that that's
an automatic dampener
on this process.
And I don't think
we should stop.
I also think there's a long
ways to go, a lot to learn.
There's a lot to do with
ethical systems and safe AI
and so on and so forth.
So a new form of life,
if it truly is sentient--
should we treat it as property?
No.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AMIR HUSAIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have
another question.
In your book you talk a lot
about opportunities and dangers
of AI in all sorts
of different aspects.
And again, I want to
encourage everyone
to read the book because it
covers so much more subject
matter than this talk did.
One of the things
I found missing
was when you write
about mind hacking
both on a personal level
and on a national level.
Right?
Is there any
solution that you see
how to defend against that sort
of-- like an anti-virus that
will say your mind
is being hijacked
or your democracy
is being hijacked.
AMIR HUSAIN: Yes.
So in the book there's a
section called "AI Shields,"
and that talks about how
you would want to use
AI to fend off that kind of AI.
Because basically
what's happening now
is that-- and we'll know
once this investigation
into the Russian involvement in
our election is fully revealed,
but tens and tens
of thousands of bots
were using very simplistic
NLG technology to not just
re-tweet but come up with
messages that were targeted.
And the intent was to
shift the prevailing
sentiment in the election.
So we've developed
systems, others
have developed
systems that can look
at that kind of
generated activity
and identify it as distinct from
what somebody actually wrote.
And even otherwise looking at
the pattern of post behaviors
and profiles and so
on to detect what
might be a very
sophisticated bot.
But ultimately this
is sort of a cycle.
They build a better
bot, then you've
got to find out ways
to detect that better
bot, and so on and so forth.
But I think that
is very critical.
The other thing which
you may like or not like,
given that this is
Google, is in my view
there's too much control
of algorithms in the cloud.
I think that-- just to give you
the very simple, basic example,
is that I want to
control what I see.
I've made a conscious decision
now that it is not good
for a social media service, and
I won't name any specific one--
all of them do this--
for a social media
service to decide
what they want to
show me, regardless
of how good their machine
learning algorithms are,
and regardless of how good
the collaborative filtering
is, and regardless of what
they think my cousin likes
or what my younger brother
clicked on yesterday.
I want to be an
active participant
in the filtering of my feed.
And, in fact, what
I would like is
I would like all of the
posts from my network
totally raw feed.
And on my end I get to
decide what I want to see
and what I don't want to see.
If we don't do that,
we're in trouble.
And if we don't do that, then
us engineers and builders,
et cetera, should go do that.
I think having this
notion of your own AI
shield and your own AI filter--
that's very, very important.
Having the convenience of
multiple data centers all over
the world and having the
convenience of not having
to buy and configure computers
and having the convenience
of being able to get to them
from any point on the world is
one thing, but then
also not control--
not even knowing what--
today I can't even tell
what the hell the raw feed
is that I'm supposed to get.
There's just no
way to get to that.
It's such a glaring omission.
That, to me, is ridiculous.
And I think that's another
area where the algorithms need
to be controlled
more by us, even
if the cloud platforms
provide the data.
And now to say,
oh, you know, don't
worry, you don't have the
compute power to filter
your own feed, nonsense.
Come on.
How many posts will
I get in my feed?
10,000 a day?
I could probably do
that on a Raspberry Pi.
You know?
So all of us can
do that filtering.
So the technical
arguments no longer apply.
It's a control argument,
and it's very important
to let people manage
their information the way
they want to manage it.
AUDIENCE: So in
the last slide when
you talk about a lot of the
loss of jobs and those jobs
potentially not replaceable
as has been in the past, there
sort of the muscle where you're
talking about labor moving
to steam engine and
those innovations
and the factory innovation
that came out of it,
but nowadays the first
level of AI implementation
that we are looking at,
like self-driving cars.
So in some ways they seem
sort of muscle plus plus.
There's a little bit
of intelligence on top.
Where do you see that heading
to in the next 10 to 20 years
where that muscle
plus plus really
becomes as capable as an
infant's mind, for example?
And what will be the impact
of that on unemployment,
if you can look into the future
five years, 10 years, and maybe
even 50 years and see
where we end up at.
AMIR HUSAIN: So in terms
of AI research directions,
I'll answer that
question in two ways.
One of the things
that I'm actually
very, very curious
about and have
been very curious
about for a long time
is this whole idea of
intrinsic motivation,
hierarchical
reinforcement learning
and intrinsic motivation.
There are many challenges
with this because--
I mean, ultimately if you--
if you say this simply
it sounds simple.
It's not very simple to go do.
But the idea is, well, you can
have reinforcement learning
pick up one task and then
you can have it pick up
another task, and then one can
be the sub-task of the other
and so you can have
this hierarchical tree.
And if you keep building
all these tasks,
then you will have a
pretty big coverage.
But the challenges with that
is whether you could really
do that and whether you can have
these independent tasks and so
on.
And second, it's
intrinsic motivation.
That's another topic that
I do cover in the book.
Andrew [? Barto ?]
who wrote about this--
father of reinforcement
learning--
Andrew [? Barto ?] wrote
about this as well.
But that is-- so where
does that flame come from?
Where does that--
so when you talk
about a three-year-old
child, to me
it's not so much that we
can't build a machine that
does what a three-year-old
child does, lifts
the amount of weight, or
can be driven to where
a three-year-old child can
be driven, in that very
mechanistic kind of sense.
The thing about a
three-year-old child
is that that three-year-old
child is born with a flame.
And that flame of
intrinsic motivation
is something that we
need to figure out.
Actually, some people
have hypothesized things,
like, well, you know, what that
flame really is, is emergent.
You know, I talk about
that in the book as well.
Emergent purpose.
I went looking in philosophy
for what that purpose is.
Somewhere along
my life I thought
I knew what I was
supposed to do,
and then one day I felt what the
hell am I supposed to do now?
And so I started
reading philosophy.
And, you know, at that
point I realized that even
people like Camus--
Albert Camus, the French
philosopher and writer--
he said things that were--
you know, the existential
nihilist movement--
he said things like,
well, that leap of faith
is philosophical suicide,
intellectual suicide
because you accept that
there came a time when
your knowledge couldn't
take you over the hump,
so you just assumed.
In other words you did
away with that gift
which was your biggest gift.
So I don't know whether
I'm that extreme,
but I do think that
that internal flame,
that intrinsic
motivation would still
be something that's missing.
I think narrow
systems that have not
a flame but a set of
criteria that they
are going to go and optimize--
you'll see that much of--
I mean, all of our
system-one-type stuff
you could pretty much mechanize.
And now if you look at
your day and you say, well,
how much system-two-type
stuff do I do?
Depending on who you are
it's going to be variable.
But I think for a
lot of jobs the job
itself is a lot of
system-one stuff.
And that then goes away.
Three-year-old child,
everything other
than that intrinsic motivation.
I don't think we have an answer
to that intrinsic motivation.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you so much, Amir.
This was great.
AMIR HUSAIN: Thank
you very much.
AUDIENCE: A pleasure
to have you.
[APPLAUSE]